- ON BEHALF OF THE FBI,
I'D LIKE TO THANK
ALL OF YOU ABDUCTEES
FOR BEING HERE AND PARTICIPATING
IN THIS STUDY.
WE ARE HOPING
THAT YOUR COMBINED EXPERIENCES
CAN CLEAR UP
SOME OF THE MYSTERIES
BEHIND THESE DISTURBING
ANAL PROBE ABDUCTIONS.
WE WANT TO KNOW WHY.
WHY?
[echoing]
- I'M GONNA BE RICH.
OH, THIS IS
THE GRAVY TRAIN, MAN.
I'M GONNA HAVE SO MUCH MONEY,
MAN.
I'M GONNA DO A BUTTER CARVING
OF MOUNT RUSHMORE
IN MY BACKYARD.
WHAT THE [bleep]
IS THAT?
[screams]
- HERE'S THE NEW
TRACKING DEVICE.
- WHERE ARE WE PUTTING IT?
- THREE GUESSES,
AND WHO'S "WE"?
- [sighs]
THIS IS WHY I MAKE
THE BIG BUCKS.
- OH!
- WHAT THE--THIS--
THERE'S SOMETHIN'
IN HERE ALREADY.
- [groans]
- AH!
- OH.
- SOME SORT OF BAG.
- HMM.
IT APPEARS TO BE
A ZIPLOC POLYMER.
[slurping]
JACKPOT!
- THIS SHIT'S GOOD.
[laughs]
- OH, SUCH SMOOTH SKIN.
- YOU THINK SPACE
JUST STOPS SOMEWHERE?
- WHOA!
- [purrs]
SHH, DADDY'S HERE.
- THAT WAS AWESOME!
- WE NEED MORE.
- KEEP LOOKING!
TELL ME IT WAS NOT JUST
A STATISTICAL ANOMALY!
MOTHER[bleep]!
- WE WANT TO KNOW WHY.
WHAT COULD THEY POSSIBLY
BE LOOKING FOR
THAT COULD JUSTIFY THE PAIN
AND HUMILIATION.